big addiction people are dealing with
pornography and all these other dishes
that changed my life now if you don't
know what nofap is it's basically this
movement that was created
where people stop playing with
themselves and they stop watching
pornography I know crazy right like why
would anyone
want to stop doing these things
but I came across this a few years back
and it's because I realized
that I had a problem I realized that hey
maybe what I'm doing isn't the best
thing
no fat for people that have never heard
this nofap this is something new also to
me no is it nofap
yeah so for the Next Generation older
generation you know many people are not
keen to these new terms like what was
this message that you were getting out
there
yeah so first off let me just say the
the shirt that I had on in the video I
think was by far the most comfortable
shirt and then I've ever had in my life
but
um no fat to get on top to get no fat
um nofap is basically where you stop
masturbating
and you start watching pornography
and for this generation or at least for
the people who are outside of religion
that's that's a big thing for them
you know like it's free
you can go on
a computer your phone and you have
access to Unlimited things that will
quote-unquote fulfill your desire
all right but that's not the the best
thing in this world and the whole nofap
movement
it's basically to eliminate these things
so that your body can kind of uh go back
to its normal State you see because if
someone watches pornography what ends up
happening is that it's releasing an
excessive amount of dopamine into your
system dopamine is a neurotransmitter
kind of like uh
acetylcholine
serotonin
things along that line all right there
are more for sure there are more
official I'm just not recalling them
right now but when you watch pornography
it's releasing this excessive amount of
dopamine
and it's excessive because you will
never have this in nature it's not
natural for you to
be able to be with let's say 40 50 60
different
sexual partners within like what 20
minutes 30 minutes it's not possible
like it's not something that that Allah
made for us
Allah didn't create our bodies this way
right so what ends up happening is that
you have this excessive amount of
dopamine and then it basically
desensitizes your body to where
you become less sensitive to real life
so let's say you walk outside and let's
say there's a butterfly that flies
across like
if you were sensitive you would look at
that butterfly and it would there would
be an impact because you'd be present
you would experience that fully but when
you are desensitized it's like that
butterfly flies across and there's this
lag time there's this period where it's
like you didn't really experience it you
just
you you're kind of running like two to
five seconds behind the time frame that
you should be you know so
to keep it more simple
um people desensitize you're not going
to notice a butterfly if you were
sensitized you go outside and you see
that butterfly and you say Subhan
and um that's that's no fat that's all
it's doing it's just re-sensitizing your
body
and were you Muslim at the time when you
made this no I was not Muslims okay so
you're actually pushing it pushing this
positive message even before Islam yeah
so this is a movement of not yet Muslims
not Muslims who started this it's not
Muslims for sure and if you get like
deep down to the bone nofap is is
actually a business unfortunately became
a business yeah but still like it's
still helping people so yeah
so it is what it is in that sense but um
nofap is meant to help people break free
from destructive habits and addictions
but little do they know
that when they break free from these
things they actually get closer to their
creator they get more spiritual everyone
who's been on nofap will attested the
same thing
this is deep uh so what do you think
from your experience dealing and talking
with this I had a guest on Imam John he
makes the connection he's lectured uh
helped a lot of the youth people who are
saying supposedly coming out and saying
look you know they're having doubts
about Islam they're having a faith Iman
crisis he connects this crisis much of
it a great majority of it to pornography
addiction
because now you made the thing the
statement now that you end up getting
closer to your creator when you start
disconnecting here now reverse that
right you keep doing it what's the
opposite is going to happen you're going
to get more distant right so he so we
did a program here and we actually uh
you have I think is one of the serial
killers on there uh he was they were
talking about FBI and whatnot they were
talking about forgot what the um
person's name
one of them yeah it was a Bundy and he
talks about how you know this violent
form of pornography how this actually
aided you know them you know with their
thinking to go ahead and commit a lot of
these crimes what are your thoughts on
that is the truth
is the truth because um when you watch
these things it's it's programming you
subconsciously
like I've I've talked to many people who
they say that
you know what they learned in
pornography when they're having sex with
their
with their woman it's not the same and
I'm like well of course it's not the
same like what did you expect like
number one pornography is fake they are
literally acting
and they're recording the people there
are people behind camera recording this
and then on top of that like everything
is done excessively to appeal to people
because what ends up happening is
people when they start watching
pornography or they start taking drugs
they have this thing known as the
Coolidge effect meaning that you need
more of the said thing in order to
experience the same feeling you felt in
the beginning so if someone drinks
alcohol
they're gonna need more alcohol they
develop a tolerance right it's a simple
terminology a tolerance
someone smokes weed the first time there
will never be another time like the
first time and every time that they
smoke weed after that they're gonna try
to
emulate and have that same experience as
the first time but they will never
experience that again
right so that's the Coolidge effect now
pornography is the same thing you watch
pornography the more someone watches
pornography the nastier the stuff they
get into
until they're doing something that's
completely against
what they are like they they could be a
straight heterosexual male and he could
be so far gone into pornography that
he's now watching homosexual
pornography but he's not he's not gay
himself but he's watching this because
he's literally desensitized himself so
much that now he needs that in order for
him to
get aroused and feel anything so just
think like if that's happening with that
like think about the other stuff
that's occurring and that's why it made
sense to me what he was saying is Imam
John what he was saying
was that because of this this is leading
to a crisis of faith of Iman with a lot
of people who are in this addiction so
what do you like to tell people who are
going through this addiction right now
they're they're tuning in where do you
like to start how do you like to help
people because this is one of the things
you do right you help people dealing
with these different addictions so
having gone through a lot of these
things what would you tell the person
like where to start how to uh
[Music]
or referring to someone who's secular
uh both okay so well it's gonna look
different for each one because obviously
each one has different beliefs and you
know different desires and stuff like
that
um but for the non-secular person I
always tell them like
what is the best version of yourself
look like
like I'm talking about like when you
watch a movie and you see like the that
character that's like the the top
character where you just like dang like
that's that's pretty dope you know like
he's masculine he's strong he's
confident he's uh he's stoic and all
this stuff all this stuff that they you
might attribute to this character now
look at yourself
I look at yourself as the main character
in your own life in your own movie now
what would this character be doing would
he be watching pornography all the time
would he be masturbating all the time
the answer is probably not
and that's like that that makes a big
shift in people who are uh secular
now for people who are religious
it's really like it's all about
understanding like what they're doing
you know like
number one do you understand that time
is running out
number two do you understand that uh
we're not guaranteed
the next hour we're not guaranteed the
next minutes nothing is guaranteed the
only thing that's guaranteed is that
we're gonna die and we're gonna be
gathered
right in front of our creator a day of
judgment that's guaranteed
now if you are religious you understand
these two things and then you see what
you're doing
well now it's a matter of like kind of
breaking it down okay why am I
going in this fat why am I doing these
things and a big one could be oh well I
don't have a spouse I'm not married you
know and I'll I'll catch on to the I'll
talk on the ones where if the Mary what
would they do but um nine times out of
ten the people who are doing this
they're not going to be maybe right so
they're trying to fulfill their sexual
urges
without actually going on here and
having sex with a woman without
performing zinner outside of marriage
you know but that I don't know which
one's worse man
I don't know which one's voice to watch
pornography or to actually go out there
and perform Cinema both of them are
terrible and Allah has already said this
but it's like in reality like when you
look at like what's happening deep down
on a uh
I guess the the neurotransmitter level
and all that stuff like even on the
spiritual level like which one is
actually worse which one is worse here
and they think that Washington
pornography is worse when like
yeah some people just that's how shaytan
plays that game he tries to just you try
to you know make justifications and now
you even have now it's it's instead of
the VH tapes VHS tapes right you have
access all over but now you actually you
can dial up people end up dialing up and
you got someone live
oh yeah the live shows and all that
right so it's getting it's getting
disgusting and it's getting to the point
where they're having 3D
the the virtual reality stuff
once it gets like deeper into that like
trust that people are really gonna be in
a rough point but getting back to what
we were saying about like the guy if if
the guy realizes that he's doing it
because he's not married well then the
next question is like okay well what's
what's preventing him from being buried
and then starting to do the work
necessary in order to become married so
that way you can get over the addiction
because the thing is with addictions is
um
if if we take the word Addiction now
it's actually just a pattern of behavior
now of course each pattern of behavior
will either lead you to Rewards or will
lead you to punishment
but if you see it for what it is and you
understand a pattern of behavior can
only be changed if you replace it with
something else
and a lot of times people replace it
with something worse you know it's like
you don't want to you don't want to
change one poison for another poison
so in this sense it's like
you want to change that pattern of
behavior with different patterns of
behavior which those patterns of
behavior could be
self-improvement you know
maybe developing yourself in your face
you know in your team and developing
yourself financially so you can support
a wife because once you do those two
you're completing or first part the
self-improvement you're completing your
50 of your dean and then once you have
the financial aspect done and you get
married now you've completed the other
50 of your Dean you see what I'm saying
so it's like it's very simple it's just
a matter of like asking these questions
and like going deep deeper down into
your your psychology and figuring out
how you're working and how is everything
going on here
it's so amazing refreshing to see
someone who went through the Journey
like you have and now where you're at
today you know giving this advice you
know with the Islamic touch in it it's
just so beautiful to see so what was
that because it's no secret now